-Welcome back
to the show.
-Thank you.
-They love you. We love you.
-Thanks for having me.
-No, I'm so psyched
that you're here.
I can't wait to talk about
all things "Funny Girl."
And also, the new cast recording
of the album.
I want to hear everything.
But first,
today's Friday the 13th.
And I was saying backstage,
I go,
"Are you superstitious at all?"
And boy, was I surprised
you're very superstitious.
-I'm a little too
superstitious.
And it's funny,
because I actually didn't know
it was Friday the 13th
until I heard you say that.
-Yeah.
-So now, I'm like, "Oh, my God,
what do I have to do?"
-No.
But how superstitious are you?
-You know, it's interesting.
I know I am,
but I realized it --
the other night,
I went out with Jonathan Grough,
our friend,
and our other friend --
[ Audience cheers ]
I know.
-Yeah, we love him.
-And our other friend,
John Gallagher, who we were all
in "Spring Awakening" together.
And they were like, "Why are
you carrying around this,
like, extremely large bag?"
And I realized that 90% of it is
just like weird good luck charms
and things that I have
to lug around with me.
-Like what? What type of things?
-I have, like, a race car
of my son's in there.
I have a Christmas ornament
that my mom gave me. [ Laughs ]
-Really?
-But it was -- you know,
when I did "Spring Awakening,"
a lot of the superstitions got,
like, a little over the top.
Jonathan and I ran through
every line from the entire show
every single day
before the show.
We had to read from this,
like, quote book
that you would buy at, like,
a Barnes & Noble called
"I Hope You Dance."
And we would have to pick, like,
a quote from it to read
every night.
So, now at "Funny Girl,"
I do less.
I just carry the things with me,
but I don't do anything.
-Good, okay.
Good, all right.
-But New Year's,
I'm also very superstitious.
-What do you do
on New Years?
-I've got to do 12 grapes.
Do people know about this?
[ Audience cheers ]
Okay.
-Wait, I didn't know about this.
[ Man cheering ]
-Whoo!
-What's 12 grapes?
-12 grapes -- there's like --
I don't even know why.
It's, like, for good fortune.
And, like, they have to be
green.
I wear, like, certain colors
and I listen
to certain music, so --
-Wowzers.
-Yeah.
-I mean, I did a little bit.
But I was never got that --
the more I think about it,
I used to cut a birthday cake
and wish I was on
"Saturday Night Live."
[ Audience laughs ]
For real.
And if I threw a coin
in a fountain,
I'd wish I was on
"Saturday Night Live."
And I really did.
-There you go.
And then it worked out.
-Maybe we manifested it.
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Aww.
-Congrats on "Funny Girl,"
by the way.
-Thank you.
-It is breaking records.
It is shattering records.
It set the August Wilson
Theater's box office record
last month, and then you beat it
again two weeks later.
-Yeah, I heard.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I mean, crushed it.
-Thank you.
And we're having a lot of fun,
too, which is really important.
-But you're just nailing
everything.
By the way, you were amazing
at the parade as well.
-Thank you so much.
-You were great here.
You performed live.
But just all this stuff.
It's a lot of pressure.
-Thank you.
I read somewhere that
Barbra Streisand
sent you a letter.
-Yes.
-The one and only
Barbra Streisand, who we love,
you got a letter,
and she said, "Thumbs up."
-She did. She gave me
the thumbs up, which I was so --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you!
-Did you freak out?
-I did. I cried.
-Of course, you had to.
-I cried.
I filmed myself opening it.
It was like, literally,
it was like a gold envelope.
It flew in on doves.
Like, you know.
[ Laughter ]
-As Barbra would.
-It came in through my window
of my dressing room.
-That's what she does,
of course.
The cartoon birds.
-Yeah, exactly.
It was so incredible.
And now it's like, I --
everyone's like,
"Are you going to frame it?
Like, what are you going to do
with it?"
-You have to frame it.
-I actually just -- I put it in
my safe at home.
-Yeah.
-And the only thing I have
in my safe is a letter
from Barbra Streisand
and my son's -- the hair --
the first hair we cut
from his haircut.
-That's perfect to me.
That sounds like exactly --
-So, it's my son's hair
and a letter
from Barbra Streisand.
[ Laughs ]
-That's the best.
-That's where it's gonna stay.
-Now, do you respond
to Barbra Streisand?
-I was able to get a message
to her through a friend
to tell her thank you so much.
But like, I don't know.
Like, maybe I could, like,
direct message her
on, like, Instagram
or something.
-I don't know. I mean, with
Barbra, I don't know.
-Barbra, I know you're
watching this right now.
Thank you so much.
-Yeah, we love you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
She's the coolest.
-Yes.
-What would you -- what will you
do if she comes to see the show?
Will you freak out?
Would you want to know
that she's there?
-I'll die. I'll black out.
[ Laughter ]
-I mean, would you want to know
if she's in the audience?
-It's funny, this is
the first show I've ever done
where I love knowing
that people are there.
It's super interactive.
It's such a fun show.
You know, Jarod, when he does
his tap during the show,
we talk to the audience,
and it's a great back and forth.
So, I love it.
-Do you act differently
depending on who -- if you
recognize somebody
in the audience?
-I would say 99% no.
But Chris Rock was there
the other night,
and I was like,
"I need to be funny."
And I just -- I have to be.
I know I need to be funny every
night, but I was like,
I just want Chris Rock
to tell me that I was funny.
Like that was --
-Yeah, of course.
-But if Barbra were there,
I would --
The other night I saw a woman
that I thought was her,
and I felt like
my mouth got dry,
and it was like I just, like,
started hearing ringing
in my ears.
-I will go -- Barbra,
if you need a date,
I'm with you, bud. Let's go.
Let's go check this out.
-That would make me feel
better, if you were with her.
-It would? I would go.
-It would make me feel better.
-She's a blast.
Can we talk about
the new cast album?
-Yeah.
-Congrats on this.
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-The new cast recording
of "Funny Girl."
This came out right around
the holidays.
-It did.
You know, it was so wild.
We recorded it.
I literally finished a show
on a Sunday
and went straight
to the recording studio,
which was very crazy.
And then finished it
the next day on Monday.
And then it was out
a couple days later.
So, it was during such
a busy time.
-Yeah, but even with that,
no one even got to promote it
or whatever -- it went to
number seven on the chart.
-It did. I know.
It's just like --
-That's massive.
-Thank you.
I know.
For a Broadway record.
It was number one --
-For a Broadway --
-Yeah, it was number one
on the Broadway charts.
But worldwide, it was like,
Taylor Swift was number one
and we were number seven.
-Yeah, we'll take that.
-I'll take it.
-I'm always amazed
by your talent,
and I'm so thankful that you
come to our show.
-Thank you.
-You are just unbelievable.
And please, hug that baby
for me.
-I will.
-Lea Michele, everybody.
Come on.
-Thank you.
-"Funny Girl" is
playing at Broadway's
August Wilson Theater.
You can stream
the new Broadway cast recording
of "Funny Girl" now.
It will be available on CD
next Friday.